vraiment quelque chose d'autre bébé ne l'
oublie pas  tu es
avec des amis de Ken qui arrivent papa
tu es une douce pièce au cul fille quand les
mots chaque centime juste un
papa de sucre avec dommage nous sommes dans un gros vieux
compte bancaire 68 gros ne sont généralement pas
si gentils
je veux juste faire  tu es heureux tu sais que
ça me rend heureux 68 000 $ Je suis une sorte de
plan et une sortie n'aime rien personne ne
se blesse
Oh détends-toi prends une pilule de refroidissement d'
accord je suis Kendrick Taylor par terre
parce que je ne demande jamais à mon dieu est-ce que je vais te faire du
mal
comme  Bon sang, nous laissons juste une femme
vous manipuler comme un meurtre et un
enlèvement, vous devez apprendre à vous défendre.
n'y pense même pas
skank où est mon
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique  ]
ce n'est pas exactement ce que j'appelle aider
la relation vérifier ouais sans blague
[Musique]
simple seul